to our top story tonight a 17 year old
girl is calling on the community for
help a few days ago her entire world
flipped upside down when her mom was
admitted to the hospital with covet 19
and is now fighting to survive sasha
loftus joins us live in studio with her
story good evening sasha christian good
evening now chelsea shin is a talented
figure skater who dedicates her days to
the sport now she's going through
something many can't imagine so she's
asking the valley to stand with her
i would never trade skating for anything
chelsean shin has spent most of her life
on the ice
she started skating at just four years
old and shares the sport with her mom
sheila whom she also calls her best
friend skating is a part of my mom so it
makes me think that she's more a part of
me the 17 year old lost her dad a few
years ago so it's just been these two
against the world but last week the
worst happened she started saying she
couldn't breathe and that's when i
noticed she had to be taken to the
hospital sheila contracted covid19 and
she's now fighting to survive
on a ventilator at sunrise hospital it's
a little heartbreaking but
i just got to like wish for the best for
her and adding to that heartbreak is a
concern to make ends meet when i first
checked our money
i was
like
and shocked of how much we don't have
chilzine is grateful this gofundme she
started is gaining so much traction
across las vegas but it's just the start
of what could be a tough road ahead
so she hopes her strength and courage in
and out of the rink
will bring the woman she loves more than
anything
back home
chelsea has already raised over 8
thousand dollars but she needs a lot
more to help with medical bills and
expenses if you'd like to donate head to
our website 8newsnow.com christian